[Musique]
c'était le 27 décembre 2016 avec ma
famille mari mes enfants
nous étions installés dans un gîte au
milieu des au milieu des vignes dans le
sud de la france
et ce jour là le ciel était juste
magnifique
le futur était radieux tellement radieux
qu'avec mon mari on avait commencé la
journée par faire des projets est ce
qu'on avait envie de relancer les dés on
avait envie de recommencer notre vie
autre chose ailleurs
on en avait même parlé avec mon frère et
ma soeur qui étaient là qui était venu
pour prendre le café et puis on est
allés se promener avec les enfants on
est et on s'était arrêté dans ce square
on s'était arrêté dans ce square où il y
avait trois cadman et on s'était assis
avec mon mari on s'était assis sur un
banc et pour la première fois depuis
très longtemps j'avais posé ma tête sur
ses genoux et je crois bien qu'à ce
moment là le temps s'est arrêté
vous savez c'est un de ces moments
parfaits un moment où il faut rien
changer ou tout lé là et puis on est
rentré on a ramené les enfants à la
maison
on les a fait manger le soir quand même
on est ressorti la nuit était froide
mais elle était très très belle et alors
on a voulu montrer les étoiles aux
enfants on a voulu leur montrer la
grande ourse
l'étoile polaire et je me souviens de
mon mari qui portait ma fille notre
fille de 4 ans dans les bras ils étaient
fiers ils étaient heureux
on était rentrés on les avait couché via
point on avait appelé un ami médecin
parce que plus depuis quelques temps mon
mari tout c'est beaucoup s'essoufflait
ça faisait beaucoup ça nous gênait
beaucoup et le traitement ne faisait
plus effet le traitement qu'il prenait à
l'époque ne faisait plus et fait donc
avec cet ami cet ami médecin on avait
décidé qu'en rentrant à paris on allait
commencer autre chose parce qu'il
fallait faire quelque chose ce n'était
plus possible
et puis on est allé se coucher
séparément
pas que les quintes de toux de mon mari
m'empêche de dormir
donc on avait fait chambre à part
lendemain matin même lumière les enfants
sont réveillé très tôt
ils m'ont pris mon téléphone mobile ils
sont en train de regarder un dessin
animé sur mon téléphone et du coup je
n'ai pas vu le sms qu'à 8 heures 12
exactement mon mari m'a écrit m'a envoyé
en me demandant de le rejoindre en
réalité moi je crois qu'il est je crois
qu'il est endormi je crois qu'il dort
encore donc je vais faire le café je
vais donner à manger aux chiens et ses
quelques minutes plus tard que mon fils
cadet vient me voir dans la cuisine il
me dit maman je crois que papa est mort
je ne le crois pas évidemment je ne
comprends pas et du coup je vais dans la
chambre où se trouvait mon mari je vais
pour le réveiller et là je vois qu'il ne
respire plus j'appelle les secours et de
toutes mes forces surtout de toutes mes
forces tout l'effort du désespoir
j'essaye de le réanimer longtemps mais
au fond de moi je sais déjà qu'il est
trop tard il est 8 heures 25
et mon mari est mort treize minutes
il n'a fallu que 13 minutes pour que le
monde s'effondre pour que je perde tout
l'amour de ma vie parce que c'était une
histoire d'amour qui n'était pas
terminée le père de mes enfants j'ai
perdu mon confident mon meilleur ami mon
compagnon
mon partenaire intellectuellement
partenaires professionnels ont travaillé
ensemble
j'ai perdu l'essentiel de mes des
revenus qui nous faisait vivre aussi
puis j'ai perdu nos projets j'ai perdu
nos désirs partager nos voyages j'ai
perdu notre futur je crois même que j'ai
perdu le futur
parce qu'à ce moment là l'idée même de
continuer à vivre sans lui est
parfaitement insupportable alors la
seule chose à laquelle je pense là la
seule chose à laquelle on pense on
s'accroche
c'est de revenir en arrière c'est ses
derniers moments qu'on veut revivre pour
avoir une deuxième chance parce que
cette fois je le verrai le sms c'est
parce que cette fois j'arriverai à le
sauver sauf qu'on ne revient pas en
arrière on ne revient pas en arrière
cette pensée ce que je partage avec vous
ils ont ces femmes habitent tous les
jours tous les jours je pense à ça et si
je partage avec vous ce soir et
publiquement pour la première fois c'est
parce que depuis quelques semaines
j'ai la conviction j'ai le sentiment que
vous et moi nous sommes en train
d'exciter exactement la même histoire
quand j vous et moi en fait je pense aux
personnes fait référence aux personnes
qui sont nées dans la seconde moitié du
20e siècle
une génération qui vit une époque
extraordinaire jeudi extraordinaire
parce que comme vous le savez jamais le
monde n'a été aussi riche qu'aujourd'hui
jamais en europe par exemple nous
n'avons été aussi nombreux à vivre aussi
bien et aussi longtemps à avoir accès à
l'éducation aux études supérieures au
soir à la santé aux loisirs à la culture
au droit de vote pour les femmes aussi à
vie à vivre une période aussi longue
période de paix aussi longue
jamais auparavant en europe personne
n'avait connu de période de paie aussi
longue que celle que nous que nous
connaissons et puis aussi à gagner
autant en travaillant aussi peu en fait
vous le savez vous le savez tout le
monde le sait parce que même si le temps
en temps on entend dire que c'était
quand même mieux avant mais en réalité
personne ne veut faire marche arrière
personne n'a envie de retourner avant
personne n'a envie de donner son
téléphone portable son accès à internet
ses vacances et ses voyages pour aller
vivre dans les années 50 ou d'arriver à
une soixante
non on est très bien on est très bien là
on est très bien entre nous garder
on est tellement bien que le jour on
reçoit un sms qui nous dit que tout ça
pourrait s'arrêter bientôt si on réagit
pas eh ben on écoute pas on ne lit pas
on n'en tient pas compte parce que en
réalité on veut pas savoir et on ne veut
pas y croire
alors on laisse ce sms du côté et
pourtant je vous assure vous et moi on a
tous reçu ce sms
le 8 octobre dernier c'est le giec il
nous l'a envoyé dans ce sms il y avait
marqué que à ce stade du réchauffement
climatique
si vous si on voulait éviter le chaos
planétaire
il était important que nous agissions il
était essentiel plus exactement que nous
agissions maintenant toute urgence et
massivement maintenant parce que si on
veut contenir la température à un seuil
qui soit humainement supportable et
économiquement viable il ne nous reste
plus que 12 ans pour diminuer pour
diviser par deux les émissions de
carbone et 30 ans pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone 30 ans dans trente
ans on sera encore là et c'est tellement
proches qu évidemment du coup il faut
agir massivement d'autant plus
massivement que le giec nous explique
aussi que même si on plantait des
milliards d'arbres
même si la technologie nous permettait
de pomper le co2 dans l'atmosphère est
bien malgré ça ça ne suffirait pas parce
qu'on n'a plus assez de temps le seul
moyen vigier le seul moyen que nous
ayons encore de sauver la situation
c'est d'arrêter d'émettre des gaz à
effet de serre et du carbone et les
solutions on les connaît elles sont
simples en réalité à votre échelle à la
mienne s'est arrêté de manger de la
viande ou en tout cas on mangeait très
peu c'est 'circulez un peu moins voire
beaucoup moins en voiture préférée les
mobilités douces le vélo la trottinette
les transports en commun c'est vivre
local utilisé les circuits courts manger
bio et puis c'est essayer d'arrêter
enfin c'est pas essayer si réussir s'est
arrêté de prendre l'avion
sauf quand c'est vraiment un indice
ensemble ces mesures on les connaît vous
les connaissez on a suffisamment dit on
le connaît on le sait et on ne fait pas
on ne fait pas parce que parce qu'on est
très bien comme ça on est pas le trait
on n'est tout simplement pas prêt on n'a
pas envie et puis après tout c'est
compliqué à la limite si il ya des
choses qu'on peut faire
par exemple on trie nos déchets on
change nos ampoules qu'elle consomme
moins d'énergie
on a arrêté de prendre des sacs en
plastique au supermarché tout ça on peut
le faire mais de là et puis oui ou non
il ya une autre chose qu'on fait aussi
maintenant c'est qu'on donne de l'argent
à des associations pour quelle plante
des arbres comme ça ça peut compenser le
carbone qu'on a envie de continuer à
émettre
mais deux là alors ça tout ça on peut le
faire mais de là à se priver d'un poulet
grillé ou d'un steak au barbecue avec
des copains nom de là a passé 45 minutes
matin et soir dans un ter bondée et
surchauffée
avec deux changements et 10 minutes de
marche alors qu'on peut passer le même
temps et même un peu plus s'il le faut
dans une voiture climatisée avec la
musique sa la radio et son téléphone
portable
non on n'est pas non on n'est pas prêt
et puis en plus quand on y réfléchit
renoncer à je sais pas renoncer un
week-end en grèce parce qu'il faudrait
prendre l'avion il faut pas prendre
l'avion ben non non surtout quand les
les compagnies low cost nous permettent
de faire des vols très bon marché elle
est passé un très bon week-end pour un
prix très faibles donc on n'est pas prêt
puis d'ailleurs est ce que ça change
vraiment quelque chose tout ça est ce
que vraiment si on arrête de prendre
l'avion ça change quelque chose
après tout pourquoi en plus on
s'arrêterait de manger de la viande si
les américains continuent d'en manger
pourquoi est-ce qu'on arrêterait de
rouler en voiture si tous les indiens et
les chinois achètent une voiture
et puis pourquoi est ce qu on priverait
nos enfants de quoi que ce soit si
ailleurs dans le monde d'autres femmes
font quatre ou cinq enfants continuent
de faire quatre ou cinq enfants
moyenne non moi si je fais un effort si
vous faites un effort on est d'accord
c'est parce qu'on veut que c'est un
impact on veut en tirer un bénéfice nous
mêmes ou pour nos enfants
alors là c'est pas c'est pas gagné mon
métier de métier je suis géopolitique
géopolitologue et prospectiviste
prospectiviste ça veut dire que je dois
réfléchir au futur non pas pour le dire
parce que je n'ai aucune idée de ce que
je le futur sera mais je dois réfléchir
aux moyens dont on dispose pour
justement façonner le futur pour aller
vers ie les meilleurs scénarios
possibles et éviter le pire et c'est
justement parce que c'est mon métier que
je peux vous dire qu'en réalité sans
attendre les autres nous pouvons avoir
un impact et un impact majeur
est ce que vous savez par exemple que si
l'humanité adopté notre régime
alimentaire nous européens si on
mangeait tous autant de viande sur la
planète
et bien aujourd'hui avec la production
agricole actuelle on ne pourrait nourrir
que 4 milliard d'habitants nous sommes 7
milliards et demi sur la planète un peu
plus on ne pourrait nourrir 4 milliards
ça veut dire qu'il faudrait laisser
trois milliards et demi de personnes
mourir de faim non alors ça veut dire
qu'il faudrait doubler la production
agricole
d'accord donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
des boisés encore massivement
et puis il faut continuer à utiliser des
engrais et plus efficace possible pour
augmenter la productivité les pesticides
et herbicides
en gros il faut accélérer le changement
climatique alors que si au contraire
l'ensemble de la population mondiale
et là je pense en réalité surtout aux
européens ou aux américains
si l'ensemble de la population mondiale
adopte le régime alimentaire du bhoutan
vous savez l'autre pays du bonheur aux
boutons on mange chaque année à peu près
4 kg de viande ce qui représente plus ou
moins un steak tous les dix jours
et bien si on mangeait tous comme les
bhoutanais aujourd'hui on pourrait déjà
nourrir 12 milliards d'habitants 12
milliards c'est à dire à peu près la
population qu'on attend en 2100 ça veut
dire aussi que
ap eu besoin d'augmenter la production
agricole dès aujourd'hui on en a assez
on en a même trop
donc on peut tout de suite arrêter la
déforestation on peut tout de suite
arrêter d'utiliser autant d'engrais de
pesticides herbicides tout de suite
c'est fabuleux non je rappelle que
l'agriculture c'est un quart du
réchauffement climatique aujourd'hui
vous voyez un petit peu l'impact qu'on a
et c'est pas les bhoutanais et c'est pas
les indiens qui sont végétariens qui
peuvent avoir cet impact là il est
japonais qui mangent du poisson c'est
nous c'est la même chose pour les
voitures d'ailleurs je vous parlais des
indiens je pense que vous savez que dans
quelques années ça sera le pays le plus
peuplé au monde
savez vous combien il y a deux voitures
aujourd'hui on a deux voitures
particulières en inde 40 millions ça
paraît beaucoup attendent et combien il
ya de voitures en france 32 millions une
voiture pour deux personnes une pour 32
en inde alors vous croyez que c'est les
indiens qui peuvent faire la différence
avec leur voiture et pour reprendre
l'histoire du contrôle des naissances
ce que je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
mais depuis un ou deux mois on en parle
énormément parle à nouveau beaucoup de
surpopulation mondiale de bombes bombe
démographique pour évoquer pour dire que
éventuellement le contrôle des
naissances a serait une solution à notre
problème de biaudos climat mais de quoi
est ce qu'on parle exactement on est
d'accord qu'on parle de l'afrique
puisque en gros tous les pays développés
et presque tous les pays émergents qu'à
la chine le brésil la thaïlande la
tunisie tous ces pays là ont déjà fini
leur transition démographique ça veut
dire que les familles font déjà peu
d'enfants moins de deux par femme en
dessous du seuil de renouvellement des
générations
donc on peut plus changer grand chose
donc ça veut dire qu'il veut se
concentrer sur les pays ont fait encore
beaucoup d'enfants et c'est à dire
quelques pays d'asie du sud et l'afrique
subsaharienne
c'est à dire aussi des pays où on ne
mange pas de viande ou très peu et
auront pas en voiture
aujourd'hui si on supprimait la suite
l'afrique suprême subsaharienne de la
carte
en gros ça ne changerait rien à
l'évolution du climat et puis l'autre
chose qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que même si aujourd'hui les femmes
africaines décidé tout d'avoir moins
d'enfants à partir de maintenant
en réalité la population africaine
continuerait d'augmenter pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'inertie
démographique parce qu'il faut au moins
une génération pour infléchir cette
progression démographique pour infléchir
la courbe de la population c'est logique
le temps avoir des enfants
une génération une génération 25 30 ans
ah oui mais on n'a plus ce temps là on
n'a pas trente ans on a 12 ans pour
diviser par 2 nogal nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre 12 ans fait rien fait
rien allez à l'échelle de l'histoire de
l'humanité 12 ans et à peu près les 13
minutes pendant lesquelles mon ma vie a
basculé
les treize minutes où j'ai tout perdu
tout mon monde s'est effondré
les treize minutes qui ont décidé que
mes enfants vivraient samper sais rien
je vous dis ça et en même temps je suis
bien persuadé que vous allez pas sortir
de la sphère en devenant végétarien et
en allant vendre votre voiture
je vais pas sûr que cela suffise et si
ça suffit pas c'est parce qu'en fait
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est pas les
chiffres que je viens de vous dire même
s'ils sont exacts
l'essentiel est là essentiel c'est le
déclic c'est le déclencheur c'est ce
moment intime où on sait ce qu'on doit
faire on sait qu'on doit agir ça vient
des tripes et c'est ce moment où on
ressent qu'on a plus du tout le choix on
n'a plus le choix
on n'a plus le choix on sait en 1940
qu'on doit désobéir et qu'on doit entrer
dans la résistance
c'est ce moment là c'est ce moment où on
apprend qu'on est enceinte et on sait
qu'on doit arrêter de fumer
c'est ce moment où on lit le sms du giec
et on sait qu'il faut agir
parce qu'il est insupportable de penser
que dans 30 ans vous et moi nous serons
face à nos enfants pour c'est bien à vos
enfants les avait en tête voulaient
regarderai je les regarderai il on
devrait leur expliquer pourquoi 30 ans
plus tôt quand on avait encore les
moyens et le temps de leur épargner le
pire
les futurs possibles on a choisi de ne
pas le faire
ce matin là moi ce temps ce choix là je
ne les avais pas mais vous aujourd'hui
vous l'avez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]